hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my agent Carter episode 6 video all
about pushing deeper into the Leviathan
plot learning a little bit more about
who they are just a quick reminder -
there's only two episodes left there's
only eight episodes in the season so if
they get picked up for a season - which
they totally could it sounds like they
will that will also probably be just
eight episodes so just careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet starting with top five
moments number five
Leviathan flashback this is really more
exciting as a dotty flashback just
because she looks so awesome being evil
we get to see the psychiatrist who I
actually thought was the engineer I
thought he told them that he was an
engineer so he might have just been
lying to the Howling Commandos to
infiltrate the SSR plans within plans
within plans based on this scene it
seems like Leviathan is a little bit
different from what they are at the
comics the TV show is just using them as
a straight-up Hydra type organization so
they're working within the Russian
government Leviathan in the comics is
really part of the secret warriors
storyline during like Dark Reign secret
invasion if you want to read more just
just read secret warriors which is
interesting because agents of shield
right now is borrowing a lot of aspects
from the secret warriors storyline
moving at to number four Angi world's
most amazing actress so they set it up
early in the episode she wants to follow
her dreams but she's getting really
discouraged Peggy's like don't give up
cut till later in the episode where
she's like you're the world's best
actress I mean she's just able to
distract Thompson by crying it's a bit
of a trope the grown men can't handle
women crying but it was kind of funny
the way they used it it's always funny
watching actors pretend to act they go
like way over the top and then and then
Peggy was like you are amazing you
shouldn't do anything else I mean of
course she's a terrible actress what I'm
really hoping develops at the end of the
season is that Peggy inducks Angie into
whatever becomes shield in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe shield was created as
a separate organization and they just
kind of rolled the SSR into that so
hopefully we'll see it at some point and
I really like Lyndsy Fonseca on the show
so hopefully they'll keep her character
around she'll become part of that too
part of being a spy as being a really
great actress so Peggy just needs a
teacher at martial arts moving on to
number three
Peggy takes down an entire department
that fight scene was on par with
anything that arrows done arrow probably
has the best stunts of any of the comic
book TV shows just across the board but
I feel like this fight scene in the
automat was on par with anything they've
done this season so
or yeah there's not as much blood it's
not quite as crazy but I feel like the
scene as a whole was just as well
constructed as any of arrows fight
scenes don't you just feel like these
scenes though turn Peggy into a
superhero like Captain America style she
kind of has some of the same moves that
he has obviously he's like 10 times
stronger but you get the idea there's
been this huge shift in the weight fight
scenes are filmed especially on
television since the Bourne trilogy is
all about the use of improvised weapons
and my number one moment
Peggy gets captured and now the SSR has
Captain America's blood to be fair they
had his blood before they did they just
didn't know it was his blood I'd be
willing to bet that that is what the
psychiatrist is trying to get the stark
tech he's trying to get last week's
episode when when they found out about
the weapon of mass destruction that kind
of seemed like the end game but I think
that they're also after the Captain
America blood so they can make their own
army of super soldiers they ended things
in a way that made it seem like Peggy's
in deep but I do think that agent
Sousa and agent Thompson will help her
there's only two episodes left so it's
not like they're gonna wait till like
the last 10 minutes of the final episode
for them to finally believe her and go
after the villain but they still don't
know that the psychiatrist is a double
agent
and neither does Peggy and for those
that are wondering that ring of his that
he uses to hypnotize people I don't
think that that's special I think that's
just something he uses to catch people's
eyes something he uses to distract
people they had that weird music cue
that made it sound like it was giving
off some weird hum but I don't think
that's the case I think it's just a
normal ring let me know though what was
your favorite moment and here's my big
question for you guys how do you think
that the SSR is going to help Peggy I
mean like at a certain point either
agent Sousa or one of the other agents
is gonna say okay we believe you let's
go get Leviathan Julie seemed like he
was starting to come around on stark
like he's like okay I'm starting to
believe that he doesn't have anything to
do with this he let Peggy go chase down
some leads before he knew that she was
involved with all of it which i think
means that as much as he's a dick as
well as the other agents in the office
they'll eventually come around she'll
just have to punch him a couple times in
the face to bring them to their senses
so there weren't a whole bunch of Easter
eggs in the episode there were a couple
really awesome ones that I saw though so
first whenever they're talking about the
Starks special like the parting bracelet
that stark gives the women they make the
joke about Ginger Rogers being a secret
Russian assassin Ginger Rogers actually
played a double agent in a movie with
Cary Grant called Once Upon a honeymoon
then when Jarvis said you should have
seen her I
the darkest gates to the abyss they cut
to a shot of the Empire State Building
so during the Avengers movie when the
the tesseract opened up a portal it was
right above the Empire State Building
like that's where Thor was when he was
firing his lightning up into the
wormhole I didn't really catch any other
big Easter eggs but if you saw and he
just write them below in the comments I
already talked about my favorite fight
scene but that slap montage that jarvis
went through that was so funny
can you just picture like a modern
version of tony stark breaking up with a
bunch of different women and sending the
vision to go do it for him I didn't have
any significant thumbs down about the
episode I mean it was it was pretty
tight it seemed like they were trying to
lead us into a very obvious
assassination attempt from Daddy but
then they totally pulled the rug out
from under us so what's gonna happen
next is I'm gonna be posting a Q&A for
arrow in the flash this week and then
I'll post a separate QA for the Spider
Man Marvel announcement there's just so
much to talk about
it sounds like Dylan O'Brien is probably
gonna be cast as spider-man he seems
like the front-runner right now logan
lerman seems like the number-two pick
but Dylan O'Brien is the one that is
blowing it up at the box office so he
just seems like the likely candidate you
guys can let me know how you feel about
that I'd be happy with either choice I
feel like it'll be fine really if you're
gonna worry about something worry about
the next solo spider-man film script so
while you guys wait for all that stuff
to drop you can click here to catch up
on agent Carter and you can click here
for the spider-man marvel announcement
thank you so much for watching so let's
all high-five I'll see you guys tomorrow
you